Democrats get somber and serious about
impeachment Lev Parnas continues his
media tour and we checked the mailbag
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored
by expressvpn protect your online
privacy today and expressvpn dot-com /
Ben when Pietschmann continues apace
yesterday was the big day the
impeachment charges were walked over
from the house to the Senate in a somber
serious and sober ceremony in the it was
really sort of like watching the
coronation of a British monarch he had a
bunch of members of the House who sort
of walked this over through an empty
chamber very seriously wearing robes it
was pretty wild stuff and we were told
by the media this is a somber and
serious and sober moment this was not a
partisan impeachment in any way that
this was just the Democrats standing up
for the constitutional duties to which
they had sworn oath and yet Adam Schiff
pretending to be somber and sober and
serious and all of that
yesterday in announcing the impeachment
of Donald J Trump other Congress people
members of the media saying that this
was a very somber and serious and sober
moment for a man who spent two years
basically with a pup tent pitched
outside the CNN greenroom claiming that
President Trump was the Russian cat's
paw here was Adam Schiff partisan par
excellence suggesting really in his
manner in behavior that he was taking
his constitutional duty extraordinarily
seriously this isn't just a hit against
Trump this was something that had to be
done House Resolution 755 impeaching
Donald John Trump President of the
United States for high crimes and
misdemeanors resolved the president that
Donald J Trump President of the United
States is impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors and that the following
articles of impeachment be exhibited to
the United States Senate oh the sobriety
oh the somberness and the sadness and
the seriousness and all other s words
that you can find using a thesaurus
basically the media dragged all of them
out Wolf Blitzer talked about how somber
and serious and sad all of this was the
media are just mouthpieces for the
Democrats at this point and they truly
are now I won't say the entire media
there's there are certain members of the
media who I think on a
try to do the job I don't say that the
folks over at CNN generally speaking do
not Wolf Blitzer and and members of the
CNN team pretending that this was a
serious moment in America after spending
years cheerleading for Trump's
impeachment after spending years pushing
the Trump Russia collusion stuff after
years suggesting that Donald John Trump
is the worst person who ever lived
they're sitting there like oh my god
what a serious moment this is for the
country yeah I'm gonna go with these are
crocodile tears here is Wolf Blitzer
Adam Schiff the lead house impeachment
manager the chairman of the Intelligence
Committee was very somber yeah very
serious he read these two articles of
impeachment abuse of power by the
President of the United States
obstruction of Congress by the President
of the United States repeatedly saying
that the president of United States
engaged in high crimes and misdemeanors
everybody very much on points here
everybody understands the somberness and
the seriousness and the sobriety of the
moment is why he had Nancy Pelosi trying
to pretend that she was really somber
and serious and sober about all of this
that my favorite my favorite actual
instance of the somber serious sober
moment was Kamala Harris O'Connell
Harris she was doing an interview with
MSNBC and she was on camera before she
knew she was on camera and she's yucking
it up I mean just laughing out loud and
then the camera switches on she realizes
that the red light is on and she puts on
or her somber serious sober face and
goes for it it's glib twenty-four
wondering if our colleagues Casey Hunt
who is now with one of those senators
Casey Ari thanks so much we're here with
Senator Kamala Harris who of course a
former a 20/20 presidential candidate
serious moment these are the most
serious charges ever brought in the
history of our country against a
president I'm gonna cough up a log
that's amazing do it again that's great
one of our colleagues Casey hunt who is
now with one of those senators Casey Ari
thanks so much we're here with Senator
Kamala Harris who of course a former a
twenty20 presidential candidate I mean
there's this is
solemn serious moment these are the most
serious charges ever brought in the
history of our country against a
president the most serious charges ever
brought ever really there's not a single
crime alleged in the impeachment papers
like not one but I am I'm really it I
just I really need to use the word
sedate we need Stern like all of the S
words right I don't know why they picked
us and they could have gone with they
could have gone with portentous weighty
right there are there plenty of asaurus
items they could have gone with but with
all the s words but that shift from that
face from that giant Joker grin and that
crazy Joker laughing mean I suggested
after she left the presidential race
that maybe she was up for the part of
the Joker in the next suicide squad but
she went from that to I mean it's like
Joaquin Phoenix in Joker who has this
bizarre penchant for laughing at
inappropriate times
right big he's got an actual condition
come with Harris can't stop herself
she's like so happy she's grinning and
then she realized the cameras on shows
and the Oscar for worst congressional
actor goes to senator Pamela Harris
everybody's so serious about guys we
ought to take this super seriously
because super serious crimes are being
alleged and it's the allegations that
matter as we'll find out in a moment
it's not the actual proof it's the
allegations that matter because now it's
up to the Senate to investigate which is
weird since the Senators where you hold
a trial so you normally in the
impeachment procedure we hold the
investigation at the House level and
then you hold the trial at the Senate
level now I don't know about you but if
you've ever watched like a lawn order
episode there's a difference between the
investigation right that is the part
where the guy played lumière is out
there on the streets walking the beat
and then there's the actual trial and
that's the part you have Jerry Orbach
walking the beat and then the other part
where Sam Waterston actually tries the
case and there are two completely
different things
Sam Waterston isn't the one walking into
be gathering all the facts he's the one
trying the case it's Jerry Orbach who's
supposed to be walking the streets
finding all the evidence well the house
is supposed to be Jerry Orbach in this
little analogy and Sam Waterston is
supposed to be the Senate but turns out
the house wants the Senate to be the
investigative body as opposed to the
house being the investigator by we'll
get to that in just one second first
talk about never had this situation
where something in your car breaks and
now you are stuck because your car is
broken down
and you have to go to an auto parts
store if you're like me you don't know
the first thing about auto parts see end
up going to the auto parts store
somebody tells you a generic part it
turns out not of it then you have to go
to a second auto parts store this
actually happened to me and now it's two
days later and you still don't have the
right part you just end up calling
triple-a well why wouldn't you just use
the magic of the interwebs this is what
Rock Auto comm comes in rockauto.com is
a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com and shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it's for your classic or your daily
driver to get everything you need and a
few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door
the rockauto.com catalog is incredibly
easy to navigate you can quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices I'm not a car guy but if you are
a car guy it's even better because if
you need a real specialized part really
the best place to go is Rock Auto best
of all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got a great selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need check them out at Rock
Auto calm that's Rock auto calm see all
the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro and how did you hear
about us box so they know that we say
okay so as I say Nancy Pelosi did a crap
investigation in the house they didn't
call any of the relevant witnesses when
they call the bunch of people who had
heard third hand about stuff happening
in Ukraine and now Nancy Pelosi says
well you know really what we're
conveying to the Senate is not about the
proof it's not about the proof it's
about the allegations well I understand
that the Democrats have decided that
allegations are tantamount to proof as
soon as you're talking about someone you
disagree with that if the Brett
Kavanaugh and there's an allegation made
that he participated in a gang rape in
1832 that this is tantamount to proof
and therefore Brett Kavanaugh should not
sit on the Supreme Court I understand
this is their broad view of how do
process works but this is not how do
process work so when Nancy Pelosi
suggests that that you don't need proof
you just need the allegations and now
it's up to the Senate to investigate the
allegations no that was up to you lady
and if you had just delayed this thing
and we keep hearing now it's bombshell
after bombshell bombshells dropping
everywhere it's like the film 1917 just
bombshells
blowing up right next to the Trump
administration well if you just waited a
few weeks you couldn't call all those
witnesses like every single one of the
ones you are now calling on the Senate
to call which suggests that all of this
is a put-up job Nancy Pelosi
basically admitting as much yesterday in
any case it's not a question of saying
what proof it says what allegations have
been made and that has to be subjected
to scrutiny as to how we go forward but
it should not be ignored in the context
of other events that have happened that
would substantiate some of that we don't
need proof the allegations are
sufficient for us to take seriously the
impeachment charges again this is like
if Jerry Orbach walked into Sam
Waterston's office and he was like
listen I've got an allegation of murders
been committed Tim Watterson's like
awesome
I'm gonna go I'd like to go try this
thing where's your proof and Jerry
Orbach was like well I think my
allegation is enough like there's an
allegation it don't got a body don't got
a weapon I've got a suspect like I think
that guy did it just call it a gut hunch
but I don't really have the proof
Waterston with laughs matters often he's
a TV lawyer so even Sam Waterston TV
lawyer knows that if you're going to try
a case in the Senate presumably and for
the prosecution which the Democrats are
in this particular case then you should
presumably have some proof to back you
up Chuck Schumer however is out there
saying Trump broke the law now Schumer
is basing this on a general on a on a
Government Accountability Office report
that suggests that the Trump
administration violated the impoundment
Control Act we discussed this at length
yesterday the impoundment Control Act of
1974 which essentially suggests that the
President of the United States has to
spend money that is allocated from the
legislative branch to the executive
branch within a certain specified period
of time or issue a special message to
Congress explaining why he has not done
that the allegation from the GAO is that
the Trump administration did not explain
why they had not sent over the Ukrainian
aide and while the eight eventually did
go over the failure to send a message
was a violation of law the Democrats are
now suggesting that this sort of law
breaking is exactly why we have to
impeach Trump weird because the GAO said
that the Obama administration broke the
law on a number of occasions the GAO
said the Bush administration broke the
law on a number of occasions and with
Obama they said that the DGA that the
the Obama administration broke the law
by shifting around money in order to
secure the release of Bowe Bergdahl the
GAO suggested back in September that the
Trump administration violated the law by
allowing national parks to stay open
during the government shutdown right so
the GAO suggests that people violate the
law all the time none of that's
impeachable it's
particularly not impeachable in terms of
the impoundment Control Act because
there you have an actual statutory
remedy that is available for failure to
send a special message to Congress if
you hold up if you participate in what
is called a delay or a season of the of
the actual money and it's also true that
if challenged in court they're serious
questions as to whether the impoundment
Control Act applies to foreign aid
because the President does have plenary
power over hand how to handle foreign
policy under the Constitution in any
case Chuck Schumer against others like
this is not trivial
the GAO the GAO report this is not
trivial except for how it was trivial
five minutes ago when it was Obama but
it's true now it's not for now it's
SuperDuper pooper-scooper serious
according to Chuck Schumer the GAO
opinion especially makes clear that the
documents we requested in our letter to
leader McConnell are even more needed
now than when we requested it last month
because President Trump
simply put broke the law oh well he
simply put broke the law yeah and so did
every other administration according to
the GAO which has been making these
sorts of suggestions for literally years
the remedy in this particular case for
the quote unquote violation of law would
have been for the Comptroller General of
the United States government and Obama
appointee on a 15 year term to actually
investigate and send his own special
message which didn't so again this is
the Democrats trying to play up what
they've got it listen you you don't go
to you don't go to war with the army you
wish you had you go to war with the army
that you have as Donald Rumsfeld put it
and apparently you don't go to Senate
trial with the impeachment you wish you
had you go to Senate trial with the
impeachment you actually have and so now
you have to back fill all the rationales
for impeachment and grasp at any straw
that is available a president from for
his part isn't taking this sitting down
he's not taking this quietly he's taking
this in all caps lock trumpian style oh
my gosh like please take his phone away
from him please this is not helpful the
reason it's not helpful is because the
president should basically be saying
listen do a full investigation we're
cool I mean this is what I suggested
throughout the Muller investigation and
it turned out right it turned out that
if Trump had actually fired Muller it
would have probably brought him to
impeachment a year earlier but instead
Trump is sort of fulminating he's
bouncing against the glass box in which
the Democrats have attempted to to
he tweeted out yesterday all capital
letters the caps lock button got stuck
I just got impeached for making a
perfect phone call and all I got was the
stupid t-shirt now if he'd added that
last part we were naturally funny like
he should have done that and I think
that would make a great teacher but a
t-shirt but I just got impeached for
making a perfect phone call the man has
a gift for me Murray what can you say
yeah I I recall when Richard Nixon was
in the process of investigation and he
tweeted out I just got him paged from
making a perfect phone call I just what
in the world what in the madness the
madness yeah again none of this is to
suggest that the Democrats have the
goods they don't it is also not to
suggest that the Democrats actually are
consistent in how they wish to approach
this impeachment because they are
clearly not for example Joe Biden who is
now suggesting that we need witnesses
and witnesses and witnesses back in 1999
is saying we don't need witnesses the
point here is that they stated the
witnesses they needed they said they
need it Betty curry they said they
needed Vernon Jordan and they said they
need Monica Lewinsky and they said why
they needed them I'm willing to hear
them say it all over again but they
weren't very compelling when they said
it the first time in my humble opinion I
don't think they're needed okay they're
not needed so not not Betty curry now
Monica Lynn not any of the people in the
Clinton impeachment were necessary to
testify in front of the Senate according
to Joe Biden now of course the shoe is
on the other foot and we need every
witness all the witnesses to testify and
we need it right now
the witness that they are most
interested in bringing forth is of
course Lev Parnas we're gonna get to Lev
Parnas apparently you vaunted and
trustworthy witness in just one second
it's funny people are saying he's like
John Dean he's like all of the members
of the Nixon administration back during
the Nixon impeachment move well he
except for John Dean not being under
indictment for falsifying documents and
lying that's exactly true so in other
words it's not true like at all we'll
get to that in just one second first let
me talk about a fantastic present that
you can get for yourself your family
this year it is just phenomenal I'm
talking about a portrait that is painted
of anything you want done custom just
for you over at paint your life calm you
can have an original painting of
yourself your kids your family a special
place a cherished pet and a price you
can afford
from paint your lifetime we have one of
me and my wife
kids hanging over our mantel at home
right now it is gorgeous it's beautiful
and not only do people comment on how
nice it is it's wonderful to walk into
my house and see this portrait of my
family every time I walk in it really
does mean a lot to me they do an amazing
job because here's how the process works
you choose the artist who's working most
admire and then you work with them
throughout the process until every
detail is perfect and they will just
keep redoing it until you are satisfied
with the product there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded so really no risk it's great
for the court and it's a work of art
with paint your life you get your
favorite memories transformed into a
work of art that will be cherished
forever it makes a truly special gift
for somebody that you love or for
yourself right now as a limited time
offer you can get 30% off your painting
that's right 30% off which is a
fantastic deal and free shipping to get
this special offer text Ben 264 thousand
that's my name Ben 264 thousand texts
Ben be en 264 thousand and you can get
30% off your painting this is an amazing
amazing gift makes a great gift for
Valentine's Day Father's Day Mother's
Day or just a birthday it's just it's
great I mean I enjoy it again I plan on
getting one for my parents it's really
really good go check it out right now at
paint your life comm and text Ben 264
thousand for the special deal Ben -
64,000 okay so the Democrats have now
decided to place their faith in a guy
named Lev partners who the hell is love
partners well he's sort of a Ukrainian
fixer who was going around Ukraine on
behalf of Ukrainian oligarchs trying to
get Ambassador Marie Ivanovich fired
that's not according to me I scouring
the Department of Justice the Southern
District of New York has harness under
indictment right now for attempting to
funnel money through straw donors into
the u.s. in into congressional elections
in order to try and skew the process
against US ambassador Murray Ivanovich
on behalf of the Ukrainian oligarch that
is according to the actual DOJ
indictment papers okay and the DOJ
indictment papers are coming from the
Southern District of New York which of
course is the same Southern District of
New York which was investigating the
whole Michael Cohen thing so this is not
like Trump's DOJ William bar trying to
go after people to silence that that's
not what this is it all right love
Parnas is in all likelihood guilty as
sin and was accused of falsifying
documents in that process he's just
lying in that process
he's accused of a bevy of crimes in that
process well he and Igor Froman became
served Rudy Giuliani's Sherpa guides
around Ukraine right he would Rudy would
go
Ukraine in search of information about
the CrowdStrike
server he'd go to Ukraine in search of
information about Ukrainian election
interference and shock of shocks
there's lump arnis and you go from him
both of whom are apparently working on
behalf of Ukrainian oligarchs saying to
Rudy
you know Rudy you know we can help you
out and you know what we'd love what we
would love and it would let me give you
some bad information about the same
bassinger maria vonage you're out here
trying to investigate what was happening
in ukraine let me tell you this
ambassador you're monitoring bad lady
she's trying to obstruct exactly what
you're trying to do you should tell the
President to fire her that's what was
really going on well now left Parnas is
being trotted out he's under indictment
he's on bail he's out on bail right now
he's being trotted out and he is
appearing on all the media using a
full-on media tour in the same way that
Michael Cohen's in a full-on media tour
he's become a hero of the resistance why
will he appeared on Rachel Maddow the
other night and while he's on Rachel
Maddow he suggested this was all top
down that Trump was instructing him to
dig up dirt on Murray Ivanovich the
Trump was instructing him to falsify
information about Joe Biden and trying
to convince will have Parnas to act as a
go-between to the Ukrainian
administration to try and get them to
announce some investigation into into
Joe Biden now do you think that he was
working for Trump or do you think that
he was blaming both sides uh the
indictment suggests that he was
certainly not working specifically for
Trump that he was doing all of this
stuff years in advance of Trump but now
he's trying to lay it all at Trump's
feet because if it's Trump's fault it's
not his fault if he was just following
orders then it's all on Trump the
impeached president and now left Parnas
is just an innocent an innocent abroad
in Ukraine being caught up in the wily
schemes of President Trump and would be
Giuliani well now that's a convenient
narrative it's a very convenient
narrative for the Democrats but it
happens not to remotely resemble
anything credible right over at hot air
and Morrissey has a piece on this he
points out that Maddow asked artists you
believe that part of the motivation to
get rid of ambassador Jovanovic was that
she was in the way of an effort to get
the government of Ukraine to announce
investigations of Joe Biden and partner
says that was the only motivation there
was no other motivation well as had
Morris he points out no the pending
indictment against parn has put his
efforts against Jovanovic at least a
year earlier on behalf of Ukrainian
official the indictment is absolutely
clear on this point furthermore last
November partners put the effort in
April 2018
rather than spring of 2019 so before in
other words he was attempting to push
Trump or push Giuliani on behalf of
Trump Matt out didn't bother to ask
about the incitement or Parnas his own
previous account when partners claim
that the Biden probe was the only
motivation the Department of Justice
never alleges this had anything to do
with an investigation of any other u.s.
person but only intended for the removal
of Jovanovic for the purposes of one or
more officials in the Ukrainian
government at the time the government of
Petro poroshenko both the timing and the
specifics of harnesses straw man actions
tend to corroborate that point far more
than they do Parnassus later claimed
that this had to do with Trump's 20:19
interest in getting at Vladimir zalenski
to pursue a Biden probe so in other
words Lev Parnas is probably lying not
only his left partners probably lying
the man is indicted on charges of
falsifying documents and the Democrats
are out there like well he presented us
with documents you mean the guy who's
under indictment for falsifying
documents gave you documents I cannot
believe this Wow what are those
documents by the way they're handwritten
contemporaneous notes by Lev Parnas on
hotel stationary so by the way there's
no way to check the metadata to find out
when he input this stuff there's no way
to find out whether he was on the phone
with Rudy Giuliani when all this stuff
was happening in other words a guy who
is being tried for lying and falsifying
documents and acting on behalf of
Ukrainian oligarch is claiming that
Trump made him do it and the media are
just lapping this up lapping this stuff
up well folks in Ukraine no partners and
no Froman are like nah I'm not gonna buy
this stuff that Dima
pristiq oh is the Foreign Minister of
Ukraine he's like no I don't believe a
word that partner says why would anybody
believe a word the partner says frankly
I never spoke with this individual and
again frankly I don't I don't trust any
word he is now saying the assistance
which we he is referring to was reviewed
on each and every year annually at least
twice and half a year at the end of the
year so we knew that this assistance is
to be reviewed sometimes it would be cut
because of the some political
understanding of what is to be done in
Ukraine sometimes it's being raced which
is now we're observing okay so official
in Ukraine right foreign minister if you
can current foreign minister of Ukraine
says I don't believe a word that Paris
is saying and now over here in the
United States you get all of the
Democrats in their allies in the media
but I repeat myself who are out there
talking about how credible partisan so
here's Nancy Pelosi a very serious
somber sober and solemn
person talking Mahalo harness is
unbelievably credible incredibly
credible we should take him SuperDuper
pooper-scooper seriously do you believe
that that harness should be a witness at
the trial and if you believe he would be
credible it relates to the documents and
the rest it certainly raised his
questions he'd be a credible witness if
what he's testifying to relates to the
issue at hand the president's behavior
why would he be a credible witness as to
the president's behavior when he even in
his interviews with MSNBC and CNN is not
saying and so the president said to me
and he keeps saying I know the president
yeah there are some pictures of him with
the president the president also takes
pictures with a lot of folks the
question is not whether he's in a
picture with Trump the question is
whether Trump actually instructed Parnas
to do anything and even parlous is not
alleged that Trump directly instructed
him to do anything at best partes
alleges that Giuliani instructed him to
do things which again creates a gap in
communication between Trump and Parnas
it also creates the question of whether
harness was told by Giuliani for example
to try and obtain an announcement of a
Biden investigation or whether he was
told by Giuliani to obtained by an
investigation and Parnas wrote down all
we need is an announcement I'll have
satisfied my guy and then they'll fire
Maria von omits right so all of this
gets a little bit complicated bottom
line is harness is not credible by
pretty much any any metric and yet the
Democrats in the media are trying to
paint it otherwise okay so you've got
Andy McCabe I love this Andy McCabe who
literally lost his pension because he
apparently lied to the FBI because he
was leaking things to the media he's
leaking to The Wall Street Journal about
Hillary Clinton and they McCabe who now
is a hero of the resistance because
anybody who opposes Trump is a hero of
the resistance and again who lost his
pension for allegedly lying about
talking to the media is now talking
about credibility on CNN a network that
spent two years pushing the Russia stuff
and here's Andy McCabe saying I believe
him I believe him I do I believe Lev
Parnas it's a contemporaneous
recollection of what he was hearing on a
telephone conversation according to him
you could then match that note up to the
booking record of proving that he was in
fact in the hotel at that time you could
also compare it to his phone records
from the days he was there and show how
many times he talked to Rudy Giuliani
during that stay so there's
different ways that you could begin to
bolster that testimony and it makes that
record speak more clearly
it's just I'm sorry Annie McCabe who
again lacks his own credibility sitting
there and talking about love partners
being a credible witness and presenting
documents documents presented by a guy
who's accused of falsifying documents
it's just amazing MSNBC's Nicole Wallace
she just straight out says it Partners
is a truth teller
he's a truth teller I love that Nicole
Wallace is saying this to Brian Williams
the serial fabulist who suggested that
he was nearly shot down in a low copter
over a rock and also that he lands it on
the moon with Neil arms the credibility
crisis in our media and in our
government has I mean all-time high here
here's Nicole Wallace trying to talk up
a guy who's under indictment for being a
liar you know we've been looking for a
John Dean Donald Trump's know Richard
Nixon there was never gonna be a John
Dean but maybe in love Parnas there's a
truth teller that also has that ability
to wake these Republican senators up and
say you know what the truth will be
known where do I want to come down when
history tells that story the truth will
be known through people like Liv partes
mm-hmm okay so let's hear directly from
a lab partner so partners was doing his
media to her and yesterday he believed I
believe he was on CNN with Anderson
Cooper and he started talking about what
a rough life he has loved partners here
he is talking about how there are
threats upon his life there's still rock
till this day there's still written not
recovered and I don't know when they
will you have no doubt they they felt
this pressure this was this was a oh my
god of course absolutely essential
threat to the survival well the main
reason my life was threatened because of
that and then he can he said why won't
they call me as a witness they need to
call me as a witness why won't they call
me as witness because her inner
indictment for lying I mean like would
that be something why should that
because you are wildly attempting to
spin so that maybe you can be offered
some sort of plea bargain maybe because
of that because you have a series of
conflicting interests but apparently
according to left partners they should
call them as a witness because he knows
all of the things all of the things if
you really look at I should be their
best witness I should be their
number-one witness because I'm the one
they got all the dirt
supposedly why aren't they calling me to
the testifier why do they need bite
call me ask me what I did wrong
Jan you're afraid of pulling I think
they're very afraid of me
I think they're afraid of me because I
think they made a mistake by you know
trying to do what they did to me okay
first of all dude needs a haircut
second of all Anderson Cooper sitting
there and very solemnly and soberly
saying to love partners do you think
they're afraid of you do that I love
that line by left partes why do they
need to call hunter Biden why can't they
just call me well first of all even if
you knew stuff about hunter Biden
hundred Biden be the person they would
call since he's the subject of the
inquiry when it comes to his activities
in Ukraine just gonna point that out but
it's amazing how the media are taking
this guy seriously hey Jay I ripped on
CNN earlier and I said there are
exceptions in the media to the rule that
CNN is very bad Jake Tapper does some
good work on CNN for sure and now full
disclosure I know Jake I like Jake I
think Jake's a good guy but Jake Tapper
yesterday he says the correct thing he
says why and we disagree politically
obviously Jake says why exactly are we
taking Aparna seriously like Jake Tapper
still has enough of a prefrontal cortex
to be like um guys really this this one
over this guy seriously him we can't
ignore harness has a serious credibility
problem he's under indictment for
campaign finance charges the Foreign
Minister of Ukraine told CNN's
Christiane Amanpour that he doesn't
trust a word Parnassus saying and yet I
see people out there in social media
Democrats acting as if this guy is the
second coming of Theodore Roosevelt
correct Jake Tapper hitting the nail on
the head this is exactly right now the
big problem for the Trump administration
is that because from is so unpredictable
and because he is so bad with his comms
team and he is oh they should be frank
about this very often his comms team is
out there unwilling to say things
because they just don't know what Trump
is going to say next Trump does not
communicate with his comms team he does
not communicate with the people in
communications he does not tell them
what the actual story is so they can go
and defend the story instead he sort of
throws them out there on TV and then he
watches TV to see how loyal they are to
him and then he may undercut their story
the very next day and so you end up with
awkward situations like this we're
coming on Conway is being asked about
left Parnas and she's asked directly
like several times is left on his line
and Kellyanne Conway refuses to say that
harnesses lying now people are taking
this as the reason she won't say that
he's lying is because she knows that
he's not lying in reality let me take
take this take my word for it in reality
what's really happening here is that she
does not know whether left harness is
saying anything that is true or false
and she is very much afraid that she's
going to say left harness is lying about
something and then Trump two seconds
later is gonna come out and contradict
her because he's not actually
coordinating with his own comms team so
this is not coming from a place of
Kellyanne Conway knows that webparts is
telling the truth this comes from a
place of Kellyanne Conway has no idea
whether it'll impart Routh just like
anybody else on planet earth except
presumably for President Trump and Rudy
Giuliani
so here's Kellyanne Conway the media are
trying to miss out is proof that the
Trump administration knows full well
that love partners as a truth teller
that's not what this clip is what is the
White House's position and his
allegations that are now public well
remember people go on TV are never under
oath
this is someone who hadn't come forward
to his own volition are you saying
flat-out a hundred percent what he
alleges is not true yes when my partner
says speaker to the court of law when he
says the president knew all of my moves
is he lying or not Kellyanne well he's a
proven liar he's been indicted is that
statement true or false
Trump knew what was going on how in
other words what his love heart is
actually saying he's saying the
president knew all of my moons way so
again this is being tried out as proof
that that Kellyanne Conway won't say
that straight out that he's lying she
doesn't know whether yours line hey
Kelli Ann Conway has no idea whether
he's lying that's what happened in that
clip the media are saying well that's
cuz the White House refuses to just say
that left Parnas is lying well no it's
because Trump doesn't communicate with
his comms team in five seconds from now
Trump will come out and just say that
well partners is a liar and some sort of
presser you watch it's going to happen
okay in just one second we're gonna get
to Chris Matthews doing something right
it's unbelievable I've actually gonna
praise Chris Matthews running out here
with that messed up hair I must stop
come with a show we'll get to that in
one second first it is that glorious
time of the week when I give a shout-out
to a daily wire subscriber is it you is
a you well today it's Rob so Rob if Rob
is you then yes Rob on Instagram is
helping his toddler son JJ get through
cold and flu season with the best remedy
known to man in the pic little JJ is
sitting on the couch in his camo shirt
taking a big swig out of his dad's
glorious
leftist ears tumblr the caption reads
mr. Benn I have a cold but at least I
have these leftist ears to soothe my
sore throat jayjay hashtag leftist
here's tumblr good for you
there is no cure for the common cold but
you can alleviate the symptoms with
leftist ears tumblr jayjay we're sorry
you're feeling bad but your dad has
fixed you up right thanks for the
shoutout we hope you are on the men soon
and we trust that you soon will be if
you are not already a daily why remember
you are missing out right now using
promo code Shapiro you'll get 10% off
any plan that you choose head on over to
daily wire comm / subscribe pick the
plan that is correct for you for as
little as 10 bucks a month members get
our articles had free access to all of
our live broadcast and show library the
full three hours of the Ben Shapiro
shows select bonus content access to the
mailbag and more plus our new all-access
tier gets you into exclusive live online
Q&A discussions with me Andrew Clavin
Matt Walsh Michael Mills Plus daily wire
writers and special guests and don't
forget you'll also get the greatest of
all beverage vessels the left is tears
tumblr you get all of that plus 10% off
when you use promo code Shapiro so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
when President Trump did have one word
when it came to the media asking him
about lab partners yesterday he was at
the White House and Jim Acosta and
ladies find you somebody who loves you
like Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta over at
Siena Jim Acosta starts shouting at him
he starts shouting at him from the back
and Trump treats Acosta with the
disdains which we have all become
accustomed here we go a conversation
that I remember with him Acosta has this
unfortunate habit of trying to talk over
president Trump and Trump shuts him down
of course this is a sign of the war I'm
the media by the way the media are very
upset today
it's a war on the media among
Republicans the very upset at martha
mcsalley who i like the senator from
arizona yesterday as i said on the show
she called Manu Raju who's a reporter
for CNN a liberal hack now no mana Roger
I've seen his reporting and I actually
don't think that he is one of the more
hawkish CNN reporters so i think that
you know martha mcsalley was either
ticked off in the moment at CNN
generally or she was attempting to play
a political game whereby she attacks a
reporter and this is popular with the
republican base obviously the media one
nuts over this here's martha mcsalley
calling Manu Raju a hack
Sally should the Senate consider new
evidence as part of the impeachment
trial you're a liberal hack I'm not
talking to you you're not gonna comment
okay and then men and then man who rouse
you of course talked about this on
Twitter's and all the rest of it martha
mcsalley it was on see who was on laura
ingraham show last night in she was
pointing out that CNN is in fact a
liberal hack network if she had said
that i'd be defending her like
Foursquare today because that today that
is a fact of life
okay CNN is a left network and honestly
you're not proving that your objective
Chris Cuomo and the your network is
objective when you then go on air and
you start berating martha mcsalley as
though somebody just called you Fredo
and let me tell you he's not afraid of
no one should ever use the word Fredo to
describe Chris Cuomo Fredo is like the
n-word for Italians that's what Chris
Cuomo has said so here's not Fredo
explaining why it's very bad to say mean
things to reporters
that's what was so upsetting about
mcsalley today this is a woman with home
mazing record of service to this country
and she really acted like a punk today
she did a disservice to herself and the
seat that she holds which is john mccain
but she wasn't even elected right she
was appointment she lost and like a
thorough fluke like some would say Trump
won but that sold other show Manu Raju
is not a liberal hack he is a very
well-respected seasoned reporter asking
a legitimate question she couldn't
answer it if she can't stand the heat
then get out of the appointed kitchen I
mean that sort of bias on CNN that's
what she's talking about okay really she
should have been directing her IRA
toward Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon the
twin pillars of dumb over over at CNN I
will also point out that Ilhan Omar has
treated Maharajah with nothing but
disdain whenever he asked a legit
question this is why by the way I say I
don't think that Manu Raju is actually a
bad reporter so I think that he's asking
tough questions to Democrats watching
basket tough questions who el Han Omar
get samara li dismissed by illa hand
Omar I don't remember the I don't
remember the media declaring that that
she was acting like a punk do you
remember that I don't remember that
either I remember Chris Cuomo or down
lemon suggesting she was acting like a
punk in this particular exchange this
morning you said the president traffic
what is wrong with you question about
your tweet you had a tweet saying the
president trafficked and hate I yes I
tweeted you there's a response you can
run that and have a nice day okay what
is wrong with you are you serious what
is wrong with you
you should acting like a punk there
Chris Cuomo or Don Lemon like it all I
get the feeling that maybe you guys have
the liberal hats like in the end it's
Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon who are the
liberal hacks and all of this the double
standard is absolutely unbelievable
well I will give points today to one
member of the left media upon whom I
frequently rip and make fun of him all
the time Chris Matthews don't ever say
so yesterday actually said doing true
he's talking about the witnesses gonna
be comfort and center and Chris Matthews
running her rumpled suit cometh there's
a shoe and a roll on in here and half
drunk but this time I was half drunken
and words of truth spilled out of my
mouth the tingle ran up my leg and out
of my mouth came fruit he said listen
Democrats now they keep saying that they
wanna call witnesses maybe they should
call Joe Biden why not hunter Biden
Chris Matthews doing something wrong
but go go go what do you want to ask
senator Biden just to give him a chance
to clear himself did you ever talk to
your son about taking that contract with
verismo did you have anything to do with
them doing did you ever tell him not to
do it did you ever get it did he ever
call you ask you to do a favor for these
things to be relevant questions remain
and look it's all it's a it's a total
sideshow this whole thing is the
Republican attempt to smear divides you
have to say with a fairly going after
them are unfairly going absent good for
Chris Matthews Wow for the first time
good for Chris Matthews right that is
right by the way speaking of Joe Biden
there's a story today about how Frank
Biden leveraged his famous name for
business gain is a story from ABC News
funny how the media are starting to
notice that Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden
are problematic in the two weeks before
Iowa almost as though all the oppo files
are opening up on Elizabeth Warren's
opponents and Elizabeth Warren is being
promoted I'm not gonna say that it's a
conspiracy because I don't believe in
conspiracies general but it's a little
weird
anyway ABC News has a story today in
2009 the year Joe Biden took office as
vice president a local business
executive met the politicians younger
brother Frank at a Starbucks in Palm
Beach Gardens Florida and later asked
him to become the president and frontman
for a fledgling at charter school
venture Frank Biden a longtime real
estate developer in the state accepted
the offer and over the years he touted
his famous last name in prominent
connections in Washington to help land
the company a series of charter
contracts from local officials in
Florida to open charter schools earning
hundreds of thousands of dollars over a
five-year period from the company in the
process in media interviews at the time
Frank Biden was unabashed he called his
last name Court a tremendous asset
because of the family's record of taking
care of people who need help and telling
people that brought him automatic
acceptance as he saw government
approvals for the for-profit for-profit
Mavericks in education claims of
mismanagement will ultimately bogs down
many of the schools shocking which
focused on educating at-risk teens with
troubled backgrounds in at least two
separate lawsuits Mavericks schools
faced allegations of inflating
enrollment as part of a scheme to garner
more government funding critics suggest
that when Frank Biden touted his family
name to promote the Mavericks charter
schools it was just one example of the
Biden family actively benefiting from
sharing a name with the vice-president
Richard painter who's a Trump critic but
former White House Ethics lawyer for
George W Bush told POLITICO Joe Biden
needs to recognize it's a problem he
can't
all your brothers they can't control
your grown son we can put some firewalls
in place in your own office
of course Joe Biden never did any of
this Joe Biden's son Hunter has been
called into question for basically being
a giant bagman running around the world
in just picking up bags of cash because
his last name his Biden and then there's
James Biden another one of the
presidents brothers who's fighting a
lawsuit in which he stands accused of
feigning interest in investing in a
medical device company as a ploy to
steal the company's business model
according to the plaintiffs Biden said
during the investment negotiations the
firm's quote psychiatric care model
would be used by Joe Biden as part of
his campaign for President of the United
States so now we got Frank and James and
hunter basically everyone who has the
last name Biden using Joe Biden's last
name in order to get ahead is it
worthwhile asking the question as to
whether Joe knew about any of this when
it came to hunter and Ukraine you bet
your ass it is okay meanwhile the Trump
team is now appointing its its own
defense team and some of the names that
you know and love are going to be
appearing according to the New York
Times you're going to get you're going
to get of course pat chip alone and Jay
Sekulow who have obviously been
attorneys for president from throughout
this process but the team is now going
to be expanded to include Ken Starr and
Robert Rea former independent counsel
lawyers / a person familiar with the
plan the team will also include Alan
Dershowitz who's a guest on our radio
program yesterday a statement from a
team spokesman says professor Dershowitz
will present oral arguments at the
Senate trial to address the
constitutional arguments against
impeachment and removal while professor
Dershowitz is nonpartisan when it comes
to the Constitution he opposed the
impeachment of President Bill Clinton
and voted for Hillary Clinton
he believes the issues at stake go to
the heart of our enduring Constitution
he's participating in this impeachment
trial to defend the integrity of the
Constitution and to prevent the creation
of a dangerous constitutional precedent
so the president is putting together his
all-star team
Mitch McConnell for his part I think
would be fairly happy with Ken Starr and
Dershowitz who are both pros at this
he's gonna be a little bit less sanguine
about the president's personal more
personal attorneys the the triple-n's
and the second lows who have had a
tendency to toward shall we say colorful
defenses of the President Dershowitz has
been pretty measured in his defenses of
the president Ken Starr is a longtime /
I am amused to watch the media's take on
Ken Starr CNBC had a long report this
morning about the appointment of Kansas
and they just basically went through his
resume and talked about all the evil
that Kenneth Starr is responsible for
meanwhile the Democratic prosecutors of
this case the people like Adam Schiff
and and Jerry Nadler they are just the
finest and wisest among us however the
fact is that this impeachment in the end
is going to go nowhere McConnell is
looking to get this done early and get
it done fast he would you'd like very
much to put this thing behind the
Republican Party as fast as possible I
think that is likely to happen even the
witnesses people are talking about like
John bolt and John bolt main testifying
the chances that John bolt testifies
very long because the president is going
to declare executive privilege that will
go to court the Senate is not going to
wait around for the court to adjudicate
whether John Bolton's gonna and if john
bolton goes and testifies he's just
gonna say what fiona hill his aide said
and then when it comes to the executive
privilege part he's gonna say well you
know that's covered by executive
privilege i can't really talk about that
i just saying he wants to testify it
doesn't mean that he's gonna violate
executive privilege to do so Rudy
Giuliani is covered by attorney-client
privilege gonna be very difficult to
call him or compel testimony and the
attempt to compel documents maybe they
had some additional documents in the
Senate unlikely that those documents are
deeply damning beyond what we already
know
so this means that Democrats have to
turn to their secondary their sort of
secondary defense against Trump's
reelection and that is they're gonna go
after the means of distribution of
information things are going really
rough this year in podcast land and talk
radio land they're gonna activate really
activate all of their favorite outlets
the media matters of the world in order
to go after everybody who disagrees with
the democratic candidates and try and
robbed them of their clientele and of
their base that's that's their job Nancy
Pelosi is most obvious about that she's
been going after Facebook now if you've
been wondering why is it that all of the
people in the Democratic Party are very
angry at Facebook but the number angry
at Twitter is because Facebook has
actually taken a fairly strong stand
when it comes to the dissemination of
information so Facebook has taken the
stand that they are not going to allow
fact checkers to simply prevent the
dissemination of political information
on Facebook that if you are an informed
citizen and you should see a claim and
then you should check the claim yourself
and we have fact checkers and more
speeches better speech Nancy Pelosi
however would certainly prefer that the
tech companies shut down everything the
Nancy Pelosi doesn't like which is why
they like Twitter my Twitter has already
said they're not going to run any
political ads because they can't fact
check everything
so there will be no dissemination of
political information the goal there is
of course to lower the number of outlets
capable of disseminating information and
restrict the entire system back to the
mainstream media that the Democrats love
know and control here's Nancy Pelosi
dripping on Facebook for not adhering to
her preferred policy the Facebook
business model is strictly to make money
they don't care about the impact on
children they don't care about truths
they don't care about where this is all
coming from and they have said even if
they know it's not true they will print
it I think that they had been very
abusive the great opportunity that
technology has given them they have been
very irresponsible and again as you say
these are people that we've known and
worked with I think their behavior is
shameful oh so Facebook is shameful but
Twitter which does the bidding of Nancy
Pelosi is not shameful hey are you
getting what's going on here folks
understand that the RIP on Facebook's
policy listen I think many of Facebook
policies are extremely vague I think
they're hate speech policy is extremely
vague I think that there's too much
wiggle room for Facebook to get rid of
people that are politically unpalatable
to Facebook I've sounded off on that
before but their general policy which is
that they're not going to restrict
political advertisements and they are
not gonna restrict political speech
because Nancy Pelosi wants them to do so
that is correct that's not going to stop
the Democrats this year this year is
going to turn into the Democrats
basically undermining the foundations of
accepting elections and we keep hearing
that Trump is not going to accept the
outcome of an election I don't know
maybe he won't what I do know is that
Democrats have refused to accept the
outcome of any election they haven't won
for the past couple of decades a George
W Bush wins the election in 2000 and not
illegitimate President Donald Trump wins
the election of 2016 you heard earlier
Tom lemon suggests not a legitimate
president the Republicans win the
gubernatorial seat in Georgia by 50
thousand votes not legitimate and now
leading up to 2020 got Nancy Pelosi and
the entire Democratic Party claiming
that if Donald Trump wins it's
illegitimate because he's preemptively
stolen the election unless we impeach
him things are gonna get a lot uglier
before we hit Election Day okay time for
a quick thing I like and then we'll get
to a couple of things that I hate so
things that I like today so I didn't see
this in the theater I'm a big fan of
Terminator 2 if you are sentient human
being terminators who is one of the top
three action movies of all time die hard
would be in that mix probably
between diehard and terminator to trying
to think of another action movie that
really stands up to those doing in any
case Terminator 2 is a great movie and
then they made a bunch of bad movies
right they made Terminator 3 which is
unbelievably depressing and then they
made the Christian Bale one which is
most famous for him screaming at a
lighting guy and then they made another
Terminator movie that nobody has
actually seen but apparently exists
allegedly well they made a new
Terminator movie this year called
Terminator 2 dark fate and supposed to
pick off it pick up where Terminator 2
left off and the movie is 15 minutes too
long and some of the CGI and great but
it's definitely enjoyable it's
definitely better than the last few
Terminator movies and it's got a good
Arnold Schwarzenegger is actually fairly
late the Terminator is a great part for
Schwarzenegger because he's not a great
actor obviously and so him playing a
robot playing a human is pretty
fantastic so here is a little bit of
terminator at dark fates trailer which
again watch with the wife the other
night very enjoyable I really I liked it
my name is Sarah Connor I never seen one
like you before almost human
I am human
don't you care what happens to her
because I was her
so the movie is actually kind of
interesting the the they basically make
the the new Terminator right the one
who's going to come back and kill
basically Sarah Connor again but not
Sarah Connor they they make that that
character very much like the the killer
Terminator in t2 except a little bit
souped up but it's it's an enjoyable
film I mean I honestly I liked it and
I'm it got fairly good reviews I think
the marketing campaign for it was sort
of screwed up because the premise of the
film was not made clear like the the
character who is played by McKenzie I
can't remember her last name she she is
um she seems to be a terminator in the
film but she's not actually a turn in
any case I don't wanna give everything
away it's worth the rent it's worth the
rental so you can go check that out okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so thing number one that I hate we
have to bid a fond farewell to our
producer Rebecca not because we're
getting rid of her but because she's
getting rid of us she dumped us and I
gotta say I'm a little bit perturbed
about this and a little bit miffed about
this but Rebecca is awesome and she's an
amazing producer and she's got big
opportunities on the horizon that she is
leaving to take and I'm super excited
for her and we're gonna we're all gonna
miss her here especially because this
means that our other producers are gonna
take over for a Becka and who the hell
knows what's gonna happen we're gonna
find out on Monday but since this is
Rebecca's last day I just wanted to
point out that Rebecca is fantastic and
when she is running a major movie studio
five years from now I'm gonna be able to
say that she ones work for me which is
pretty awesome so good luck to Rebecca
and best wishes obviously okay so I hate
that she's leaving that's why that goes
under things I hate it as opposed to
things I like I like Rebecca I hate that
she's leaving okay here is another thing
that I hate so the Virginia General
Assembly passed the Equal Rights
Amendment in what the media are calling
a historic vote according to the
Washington Post both chambers of
Virginia's General Assembly passed the
Equal Rights Amendment on Wednesday
fulfilling a promise that helped
Democrats seize control of the
legislature and marking a watershed
moment in the nearly century long effort
to add protections for women see the
United States Constitution
now you don't need protections for women
in the United States Constitution they
can vote they have all the same rights
than men do the Equal Rights Amendment
is a poorly worded amendment that
specifically opens the door to the idea
that there should never be any separate
spaces for men and women at all that's
what
the Equal Rights Amendment does that was
the pushback against it in the 1970s it
was led by phyllis schlafly at the time
she was correct now the democrats denied
by the way that this would provide the
basis for getting rid of gendered
bathrooms for example or gendered sports
now they just because of the transgender
movement they openly admit that this is
what they would like to see happen the
lopsided votes captain emotional week in
which democrats celebrated history in
the making
the house gallery was packed beyonds
it's 102 seat capacity with virginia
first lady pam nor them and her daughter
Aubrey nor them making a rare appearance
to bear witness the RA supporters
attended from around the country many
wearing sashes from long ago marches for
women's equality
this makes Virginia the 30th state to
approve the amendment but there is one
big problem there is one big problem the
original ER a had an expiration date you
can't just go around passing amendments
that have expired 30 years ago that's
like if the House passed a bill in 1979
and the Senate didn't take it up and the
Senate today took up the bill from 1979
had an expiration date in the bill right
that says if this bill is not passed in
three years then it is void and the
Senate picking up that bill and then
passing the bill and calling a passed
that is not the way any works okay if
the bill in and of itself of the
amendment which it did contain an
expiration date saying if this is not
enacted within a certain period of time
then it becomes irrelevant you can't
just pass it 40 years later and be like
oh well I guess the 38 states have now
approved overtime 38 because here's the
thing that doesn't work about that that
doesn't that gives Virginia a second
bite at the Apple now but what about
states that originally approved it do
you think there are 38 states that are
willing to approve the ER a today if
there are 38 states willing to approve
the ARA today then why not bring it up
in the Senate today half the states that
approve the e ra originally are not
going to approve the e ra today because
everybody understands the implications
of the e ra now Delaware Jenna a
delegate Jennifer Carol Foy of Prince
William the resolutions chief house
sponsor introduced the measure with a
litany of Virginia civil rights failures
including slavery massive resistance to
school integration and the ban on
interracial marriage because the idea is
that these things have not been cured so
we need an equal rights amendment to
guarantee their cure despite the fact
that Virginia is no longer segregated
that interracial marriage was declared
federally legal by the Supreme Court in
loving versus Virginia
believe in 1968 I met and that slavery
ended in 1863 under the Emancipation
Proclamation apparently we need the
Equal Rights Amendment because yeah
Carole Voice ed it's Virginia again on
the battleground of equality I think it
is right on time for Virginia to finally
be on the right side of history I wrote
a book on the right side of history the
right side of history was written the
title was written mocking the idea that
you can simply declare that you are on
the right side of history when history
has not yet adjudicated your position
there are very few things where you can
say you were on the right side of
history you can say it about being
anti-slavery that was being on the right
side of history you can say that being
Pro capitalism was on the right side of
history you cannot say that a policy you
are attempting to enact today is on the
right side of history
because history hasn't had a chance to
sound off you doof unfortunately this
sort of phraseology was used by Barack
Obama routinely and it was idiotic at
the time how you use a phrase is more
important than the actual words of the
phrase and this phrase is used idiotic
Lee frequently calling the balloting
that was about to take place the vote of
a lifetime
she asked lawmakers which side of
history do you want to be on the world
is watching your mothers your sisters
your daughters she's literally a female
delegate sitting in the House of
Delegates a black female delegate
sitting in the House of Delegates in
Virginia declaring that unless the Equal
Rights Amendment is passed
women and particularly minority women
have somehow been victimized you're
gonna need to explain that one to me
delegate Vivian Watts of Fairfax held up
a photo of herself and her daughter
demonstrating for the ER a in Washington
forty-four years ago when her daughter
was 14 what said it should be ancient
history 44 years is a long time to wait
you're sitting in the House of Delegates
you're please explain to me how women
have been greatly victimized by the
absence of the ER a women now constitute
the majority of college graduates they
constitute the majority of medical
school attendees women now constitute I
believe the majority of the workforce so
what exactly are you talking about like
truly what are we talking about here and
the answer is that the Equal Rights
Amendment is gonna be used as Democrats
and left's always use legislation as a
wedge in order to force their way into
areas that have heretofore been left
untouched this is the way the Democrats
work they they they push forward vague
language and then they say why don't you
support women why I'd say well that's
vague language I don't know how you're
gonna interpret that language you might
want to do this crazy thing in five
years and no we would never want
do that it's just that you hate women
right we saw this with the push for for
a same-sex marriage right that
originally started as a reasonable
request the government stay out of
people's bedrooms and it was like okay
I'm alright with that and then it moved
to know what we really want is we want
the contractual ability to get our
partners benefits when they die or they
get sick you know like okay that sounds
reasonable so you don't want to say that
same-sex marriage is the same as
traditional marriage you just want like
civil unions right that okay all right
reasonable and I said well no what we
actually want a same-sex marriage well
we want same-sex marriage for is to
declare that we are morally valuable
human beings and how does it affect your
marriage anyway does it affect you does
it affect your church does it affect
your school doesn't affect you in any
way if we're able to get the same
benefits that you're able to get and the
moral imprimatur of the state in
approving same-sex marriage and a lot of
marriages like well that one of the more
dicey on because we think there's a
moral difference between traditional
heterosexual marriage and same-sex
marriage like significant differences in
kind there because a man in a manner not
the same as a man or a woman but I guess
you want to make that argument all right
yeah I mean you're right that it doesn't
affect my marriage obviously it affects
the society at large it affects how we
perceive marriage but it doesn't affect
my marriage but you got to leave our
churches in schools alone and then like
nope sorry we've we lied actually we're
gonna come after your schools and your
churches we're gonna remove nonprofit
status with me like better O'Rourke and
I'm gonna suggest that we need to get
rid of all churches in schools that
don't approve our morality and our in
our approved way of life it this is why
the right tends not to approve vague
language on the part of the left because
the left is usually ly usually left is
saying they want something that seems
innocuous on its face but is deeply non
innocuous right that eventually ends up
exactly where the right said it was
going to go this happens to be the case
with the Equal Rights Amendment again
back in 1979 Phyllis Schlafly was like
just by the terms just by the terms of
the Equal Rights Amendment there cannot
be separate bathrooms and people unless
like no that's crazy of course there can
be separate bathrooms come on and now we
live in a world where the Obama
administration tried to force without an
equal rights amendment try to force the
creation of non-gendered bathrooms
across the country and non-gendered
locker rooms at high schools across the
country
so yes count me very very skeptical
indeed that the Equal Rights Amendment
would simply be another innocuous piece
added to the United States Constitution
as opposed to a club to be you
in litigation in favor of pushing left
to social policy without the approval of
the American people already well it's a
Friday I hope that you stick around for
two more hours of additional content
lyrics we've got a lot to get to
including the mailbag which is why you
should subscribe so you can answer your
questions in the mailbag but beyond that
you should stick around for two
additional hours cuz we got a lot of
great stuff coming up and and you should
have a wonderful weekend if you are not
going to do that and even if you are
going to do that we'll see you here on
Monday with all the updates take the
week you know what knock off tonight
take the next couple of days off and
we'll see you back here on Monday i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jess while alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]
you